sometimes we jokingly use the term brain
worms and what we mean some sometimes by
brain worms is
somebody's abilities to think critically
and consistently
are either suspended deliberately or
just not functioning
we finally got a very interesting
interview Fox interviewed a supporter of
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
and they actually asked her what about
the fact that he paid for an abortion
for a woman he urged to get the abortion
after he impregnated her
uh what about that because this woman is
presumably pro-life anti-choice
anti-abortion
and he claims to be as well
and she says
we've all done things when we were young
Herschel Walker was a nearly 50 year old
man when this happened when we were
young he's 60 now he was almost 50 when
he did this
what the hell are you talking about and
this is an example of the total
cognitive dissonance that exists and the
inability to reach certain people which
is where I'm going to focus in here but
let's take a look at this clip okay
matter to you if it's true or not
[Music]
I mean we all do things when we're young
naive
he's an adult now yeah he was an adult
of nearly 50 years of age
when he impregnated a woman
urged her to get an abortion paid for
the abortion and now in the second case
that we now know of
implicitly and menacingly threatened the
woman he impregnated by saying you would
not be safe if you did not get an
abortion and the eventual child would
not be safe if you didn't get an
abortion so there's a bunch of different
stories here let's talk about them first
is the
realization
that many of us have had you really
can't reason with these voters right
what if that woman who we just saw the
interview with
she straight up says eh he's changed his
mind and he did this when he was young
we all do things when we were young he
was almost 50. okay you can't reason
with her so what do you have to do
you have to take the money that you
might spend trying to reach those people
and instead you have to Target rational
people
to just get them out to vote so as a
political strategy we've said before
where do you spend limited resources uh
how do you invest the resources in time
that you have is it on trying to change
the minds of people like that woman
seems quite fruitless I think you would
agree at least from an election story
interpersonally sure try to talk sense
into her but as far as we have X number
of dollars to spend do we try to just
get out the vote from people who already
lean in our direction or do we try to
change the minds of people like that
you've got to just try to get people to
vote that are already that are not
totally Bamboozled and disconnected from
reality like that woman that's number
one number two this idea of redemption
this is an extraordinary get out of jail
free card for the right which is
important for us to understand
Redemption can be used to explain away
any transgression no matter what as long
as the individual has completely
implausibly repented or said why they've
changed their mind and it's used by the
right to never have to actually consider
voting for a Democrat to never consider
that the Democrat may actually be the
better choice as Raphael Warnock is in
the state of Georgia we saw this with
Trump Donald Trump
68 years of life pro-choice
all of a sudden he's running to be the
Republican Presidential nominee and he
needs some way to no longer be
pro-choice that people will believe
Trump comes up with the completely
unbelievable story well you know I was
very pro-choice my whole life this is
Trump's story okay I was I used to be
pro-choice
but I met a woman what a kid
and I met the kitten it was a great kid
and the woman said you know at one point
I wasn't sure if it was the right thing
to have this pregnancy to carry this
pregnancy to term I thought about
getting an abortion and I didn't and
Trump goes you know what my 68 years of
being pro-choice I flushed him down the
toilet 10 to 15 times because I met a
kid I liked
that's the story
I don't believe that that's an absurd
story I know many of you don't believe
that story but it's a get out of jail
free card for the right Wingers who go
he saw the light eventually yes it took
him 68 years but he eventually Saw the
Light
um on religion we know Trump is not
religious we know Trump has no idea
about religion he didn't go grow up
religious or any of it but he started
saying I love the Bible oh really Mr
President at the time he wasn't
president Mr Trump sir uh what's your
favorite passage oh that's personal I
don't want to get into that do you
believe that do you believe that Trump
is a Bible guy uh are you a first amend
a First Amendment are you a uh a new
testament or an Old Testament guy uh
both oh okay
completely unbelievable but the
Evangelical right eventually came around
and said well he came he eventually
figured out the right position on
abortion and he's religious now and he
loves the Bible and blah blah blah so
the Redemption story is a blank slate
get out of jail free card if they want
it
if they want it if they want to bury you
then they don't use the Redemption story
but as long as you've said I changed my
mind they completely uncritically
accepted if it's convenient now let's
kind of go to the last thing
speaking very narrowly and specifically
how do people like this have a driver's
license
how do people like this hold a job like
the woman who we saw there she's holding
a kid in the interview how does she
parent a child
some of these folks I genuinely don't
know how they get through the day
I don't know how they accomplish the
simplest tasks grocery shopping
uh figuring out the right amount of
Tylenol to take quite frankly I don't
know how they survive I don't because
they are so
ah
I don't even want to characterize it
with adjectives
it's
disturbing to think about the number of
folks that are this Clueless
that just live in the country with us
and it helps us understand how Trump won
and unfortunately
why Herschel Walker may also win on
Tuesday if our Georgia friends and
neighbors don't get out to vote
check out our sponsor Shaker and Spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers the craft cocktail
experience to your door each monthly box
comes with three original recipes
created by world-class bartenders with
ingredients for 12 cocktails my favorite
is the blood and Sage it's part of the
Vodka based drinks it uses herbed Sage
syrup and blood orange Meyer lemon
ginger ale delicious refreshing I love
how Shaker and Spoon includes everything
you need the ingredients the
instructions right in the Box the recipe
is easy to follow the blood and Sage
made for a very relaxing fall afternoon
on the back deck a lot of fun with
Shaker and Spoon you don't need to seek
out hard to find cocktail ingredients or
buy full-size containers of things
you'll use once this is way more
convenient Shaker and Spoon introduces
you to spirits and flavor combinations
you may never have otherwise discovered
an it is a fantastic holiday gift give
the gift of an awesome experience Shaker
and Spoon giving you twenty dollars off
your first box go to shakerandspoon.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below